My、ブラザーが遊びに来てるんですけども、やっぱ僕は、弟想いなんですよ。
んん？聞いた事無いって？そんな事無いだろ？
と言う訳で弟が今家に遊びに来ているんですけども、
ちょっと、サプライズみたいな事をして上げようと思いまして
彼もやっぱり大学生で、つまらない日常にうんざり飽き飽きしてると思うんすよ。
一言もゆってないけど
そんな彼の日常、グイグイぶん回す為に今回はこちら！
高速ドリルを買ってみました
ま、高速ドリルなんて日常的に使う事はまずないと思うんで
これでちょっと彼の日常をぶち壊してやろうかと思いまして。
どんぐらい回転するんだろうね。
回転数は、、、、
良く分かんないな。
ハイパワー、あ、高速４２００回転だ。
４２００回転ってことはどういうこと？一秒に４２００回転？
バケモンじゃないか！
こんなに回転するか？
一分か。一分で４２００回転、てことは、一秒で７０回転だ！
早い！
一秒に７０回転は十分、十分。十分凄い
それだけ十分早いってどんな具合なんだろう
ﾔﾊﾞ・・・。アーこれヤバいな、怪我する速さだこれ
ハロー　YouTube
や、待てｺﾚちょっとあぶねーなー
ゆずコショウを回転してみましょう
ダメなのか？ゆずコショウ。ゆずコショウが回転できない
ティッシュ付けたら、すっごい扇風機になるんじゃない？
うわあ
ちょっ、手が震える
はい、とゆうように今ご覧いただいた通り威力は十分わかったと思います。
ってゆわけで今回これを使ってどのように弟をこう、、、、、、、、ざぜるのか！
こちらです！シャボン玉でございます。
これ、スピードを出すと
こう、シャボン玉が出来る訳ですよ
ほら？シャボン玉がどんどんできる。
スピード掛けるとシャボン玉が出るんですよ
この原理を利用して、例えばドリルの先端に一個付けますと、
これで回すと、もうね
ほらほらほらほらほらほらほら！
ほら？ねぇ、ねぇ、マジで、
割と、うまく、
いって
ああ？  いんじゃない？
おｒｒｒ
ここの先端にシャボン玉の出るこれをつけて回転させると
この勢いを利用してシャボン玉が大量に出ます
というわけで今回、
大量にこのシャボン玉を買って来たので
この剣先の部分だけをたくさんこのドリルの先端に付けて、
弟が入ってきた瞬間にこれが回転し出して
もう回転しすぎてもう部屋中がシャボン玉だらけになって多分凄い非日常の幸せな気持ちになれると思うので
一瞬で
大量のシャボン玉を作れる超、高速回転マシーンを作って行こうと思います！
では、行こう！
ひとまず付けれるだけ付けてみそー
これぞ、ドリルの回転力を生かした
これで後は、ちゃんと向きをそろえて
ちゃんとシャボン玉が出る方向に合わせて、
回転すれば間違いなく大量のシャボン玉が出ると思われます
ｎｎんいい感じいい感じ
アリ、あり、あり、有です、オッケーです
はい、という訳で完成したので
これの一本ずつにシャボン玉液をしっかりつけて、膜くを張って
その状態で弟が入って来た瞬間にボクはこれを回します。
そしたらもう部屋中がシャボン玉だらけで弟はもう笑顔。僕も笑顔。
ハッピーな兄弟愛が見れるでございます。
では早速弟を呼んでみまっしょう！
スゲー
出てた？シャボン玉
「出とった」
どれくらい？
「ちょろちょろ」
ﾁｮﾛﾁｮﾛ(笑)、感動した？
「かん、感動しったって言うか怖かった」